how do you hire people it's like
how do you find good friends
how do you find good relationships
and in this specific case how do you
hire good people engineers
executive all of it one thing is i've
done a lot of reps on hiring at this
point so um
coinbase has about 5 000 people
um
probably the first 500 people or
something maybe in that range um you
know i i interviewed every single one of
those but you have to remember there's
probably like
i don't know on average maybe 10 people
that we went went in the process for
every one we hired or something so it
was like
by the time that we had 500 employees i
had done like 5 000 interviews or
something i was like very burned out in
interviews i had been doing
i had some days i did like seven
interviews in a day or maybe um
you know you've been you would do lots
of interviews maybe you wouldn't get
burned out but different kind of
interviews uh very different very
different yeah very different because
you're
uh
so first of all most of your interviews
lead to rejection yeah
which is also exhausting
yeah and there's a whole there's a whole
part of the interview which is about
candidate experience right sometimes you
know it's not the right person but you
want to make sure they have a good
experience like if you're just exhausted
and you're on your sixth interview and
you're like well thanks for coming in
and you rap and you just and then like
you're gonna create a detractor someone
is out there like [ __ ] that company or
brian was rude to me or whatever so i
had to honestly i had to work on that a
little bit in the early days i was doing
so many interviews like i needed to make
sure that
um when people came in i was like you
know made them feel comfortable
um asked them a couple of like warm-up
questions just like how how was it
getting in the office like did you find
it okay and like what have you been up
to this week and not just like
you know like a factory assembly line
like boom boom boom like
yeah but also there's a moment because
i've interviewed a bunch of people for
like teams and stuff yeah there's also a
moment when you early on no it's not
going to be a good fit yeah and you
still have to land that plane and yeah
and all that kind of stuff and that
could get really really really
exhausting so yeah anyway sorry so
yeah so basically we tried all we've
tried so many things over the years to
make interviews more efficient because
it's a huge time sync for
the team
so
you know we we basically will usually
get them down to like 25 minutes
i've seen if you're trying to hire like
a big team let's say
um
you know of people who are like
contractors or something not necessarily
full-time employees i've seen people
actually do 10-minute interviews
um you can even interview like a
thousand people almost like in a week or
something i'm not sure if that quite
works out but let me a little less than
that but you can basically get six and
six done an hour if you're just i need
to get a team of 30 contractors for
whatever purpose but if you're talking
about full-time employees i usually do
like 25 minute
you know you're often times like
one one thing we've done is we'll put
like a
um
like a google form online and it's like
put some basic hurdles in there like you
know ask them
um
to put in an answer which you can check
in a spreadsheet if it was correct or
not and like there were some funny
examples in the early days of coinbase
where we put in like brain teasers and
stuff but we don't do that anymore we do
like normal interviews we do references
the kinds of things i ask in interviews
um
you know it's usually like
i like to think about what what do we
need this person to accomplish in this
role right
and
get really specific about that it's like
usually something pretty hard and then
i'll ask them a question that's like
tell me about a time you did x
and um
or tell me about the hardest the hardest
kind of problem you've had to solve in y
and what did you do specifically to
overcome it right so i'm asking to see
if they can actually do the stuff we
need to get done but then i'm also kind
of asking inter like culture questions
if i'm interviewing for that
and so i'm trying to see like are they
concise communicators can they just give
me a clear
answer
and stop talking some people like ramble
on for like five ten minutes if you ask
the first question some people are you
know they're interrupters like church of
interruption so like they won't stop
talking until you interrupt them which
for me i'm always patient and i wait so
yeah that's weird
i'm looking to see for humility too like
you know i'll ask people well tell me
about a time something went really wrong
like you had conflict with someone on a
team or
um and what i'm kind of looking for is
were they part of the solution or are
they still holding on to like blame and
criticism about that and be like well i
told them they shouldn't do that way but
they didn't listen to me you know these
are all like bad signs
so i'm looking for yeah can they get the
job done will they work together on a
team can they communicate effectively
do they fit into our cultural values and
you know those kind of things yeah i
mean there's uh because i've
uh even even for help with this this
podcast here but also at mit and so on
i've done a bunch of hiring and uh i was
always looking for you said brain
teasers all kinds of simple questions
that can
that can reveal a lot of information
and it's always been challenging i i
used to i still ask this question but
uh
do you think it's better to work hard or
work smart
and
you know i had this idea
that i've
that i think i've matured about which is
i kind of believe that people who say
work smart on that question
don't actually work smart so the the
right textbook answers what is better to
work smart
but the reality is it's
it's people that haven't actually ever
done anything that
say work smart they're like uh they
haven't really struggled because my
general belief at the time was in order
to discover
what it means to
work smart to be efficient to you have
to work your ass off so you have to
really fail a lot and failure feels like
hard work
and so i was always suspicious of people
that would say work smart i would want
to interrogate that question
but then i also you know have learned
that there is
people that are just exceptionally
exceptionally efficient
they really do know what it means to
work smart even at a young age
and so like you can't just disqualify
based on that you have to dig in deeper
but some of the most interesting people
i've ever worked with would say work
hard unapologetically and they're
usually the ones
that know how to be efficient which is
it's just an interesting thing like that
and and i've always searched for
questions of that nature to see
can i can i get
can i get a person to reveal something
profound about them in as brief of a
question as possible
and i you know and then of course
there's basic attention to detail and
brain teasers and stuff like that
depending on the role programming and so
on to see can they can they solve a
tricky puzzle
and do so like one that doesn't require
a lot of effort but requires a certain
um
non-linear way of thinking is there is
there some
i mean maybe you don't want to reveal
but is there some questions
that you sometimes find yourself leaning
on
you said like how did you solve
a hard problem in your past
and yeah have them talk through it
that's one you know we started with
brain teasers periodically at coinbase
and i we got we got away from that
relatively quickly and i think
one i it's a tough one because i
actually think
it does show how somebody
kind of performs under pressure but it's
i don't think it's a super reliable
indicator because
there's some people who are really
good
in what the typical work situation but
that's not a typical situation where
somebody puts you on the spot like in
the live interview and sometimes people
get nervous and they can't think clearly
and like they don't have their computer
in front of them or whatever they
normally use
so
yeah i i'm a little skeptical now of the
of the brainteaser thing um
there is a whole
yeah
there is a whole question about like a
lot of universities are getting rid of
you know entrance exams so if you're
hiring right out of universities um
sometimes it's becoming a less reliable
indicator of like are they in that
university and i've heard some companies
we haven't done this yet but i've heard
some companies are actually creating
their own like for college grads like
their own um
basically
exams like standardized testing almost
to get people in the door because
the degree almost like doesn't mean what
it used to which is the whole topic but
yeah that's fascinating because um
it's fascinating both for that because
it's not just about you trying to hire a
great team it's also to help them find
the right place to work at yeah it's
just like it's like a two-way street
you